[Musik]
auch wenn es der afd in sachsen anhalt
nicht gelungen ist stärkste kraft zu
werden hat sich der wahlkampf für sie
ausgezahlt
mit mehr als 20 prozent der stimmen
wurde die partei bei der landtagswahl
erneut zweitstärkste kraft
die afd in sachsen anhalt gilt als
stramm rechts ist im visier des
verfassungsschutzes extrem rechte
positionen sind aber auch im westen weit
verbreitet über monate verfolgen wir
unbemerkt die diskussionen in den
geschlossenen afd gruppen auf whatsapp
und telegramm
darin äußern sich reif die mitglieder
und sympathisanten aus der ganzen
bundesrepublik
das land wird islam republik muslimische
kopftuch geschwader mit kinderwagen über
einen informanten bekommen wir zugang in
die diskussions räume der anhänger des
rechtsextremen partei flügels es geht um
invasoren in europa dreck müll keine
weißen mehr klagt ein anderer autor
man müsse problemviertel massiv mit
weißem zurückbesinnen mit aller macht
[Musik]
rassismus fremdenhass wir haben hunderte
belege gesammelt die dokumentieren dass
ein teil der afd
über ein rechtsextremistisches weltbild
verfügt er gilt als der kopf des rechten
parteiflügels jörn böcker landeschef in
thüringen
wenn wir die grenzen nicht schließen
dann werden wir eine kulturelle
kernschmelze leben und das wollen wir
als afd nicht die internen chats zeigen
die härte des machtkampfs in der partei
in einem video wird parteichef jörg
leuten der für einen gemäßigteren kurs
steht zu grabe getragen
es geht nur so dass wir ein sehr klar
konservativ freiheitlichen kurs schaden
mit einer sehr deutlichen brandmauer
nach rechts aus zdfzoom will wissen wer
setzt sich durch im afg richtungsstreit
dresden im april
fast 600 delegierten in der messehalle
die afd trifft sich zum bundesparteitag
die nerven in der partei liegen blank
die letzten wahlergebnisse in den
westlichen bundesländern waren für die
afg wenig berauschend mit ihren
politischen zielen polarisiert die
rechte partei die gesellschaft
abschottung vor der europäischen union
stimmungsmache gegen asylsuchende die
ablehnung einer offenen gesellschaft
der politologe wolfgang schröder
beobachtet die afg schon lange und
erforscht die strömungen in der partei
die afg ist eine koalition ganz
unterschiedliche kräfte das geht von
national konservativ zornig gegen
bestimmte praktiken der etablierten
parteien bis in den rechtsextremen
bereich hinein entscheidend ist eine
koalition die man mit der
begrifflichkeit des rechtspopulismus
erfassen kann das volk des gutes tut
gutes denkt und dem eine schlechte
regierung gegenüber steht
die afg also ein sammelbecken in dem
auch vermehrt extremisten ihren platz
finden
das hat den verfassungsschutz auf den
plan gerufen
was dem selbst image der afg als
rechtsstaatliche partei schadet
parteichef wollten sagt offen dass er
die rechten extremisten am liebsten
gleich ganz aus der partei schmeißen
möchte in der afg brodelt es
bundesvorsitzender die partei
augenscheinlich nicht integrieren kann
nicht integrieren will sondern der
leider spalterisch tätig ist und uns
schadet wenn dann einige hier oder da
immer noch dieses dieses märchen
verbreiten sollten
ich wurde das spalten oder etwaiges dann
müsste spätestens heute der letzte eines
anderen belehrt sein das ist einfach und
es verläuft ein riss durch die partei
auf der einen seite der gemäßigteren
kurs von parteichef jörg merten auf der
anderen seite john höcker und das
rechtsextremistische lager
ist der konflikt der lager nur
inszeniert lange zeit standen sie seite
an seite ist das ganze ein abgekartetes
spiel um möglichst viele wähler stimmen
einzusammeln
mittlerweile glaubt hat jeder begriffen
dass das nicht taktik ist sondern dass
der internet- tiefe echte eigene
überzeugung steht wenn ich zahl der
filmpreis der preis der anfeindungen die
immens sind die erlebe aber stimmt das
ein offener streit oder nur eine
raffinierte taktik zweier politstrategen
nach einem jahrelangen miteinander
diese frage stellen wir den
politikwissenschaftler armin pfahl traut
wer eine heimliche absprache zwischen
leuten und schicke würde ich eher in das
reich von verschwörungstheorien zuordnen
können
dafür sind die konflikte viel zu heftig
und auch viel zu persönlich in dem sinne
das wäre auch später nicht mehr
vermittelbar dass man kooperiert in
sachsen anhalt hat der rechte flügel
innerhalb der ard das sagen
mit rechtsradikalen positionen lassen
sich hier durchaus wählerstimmen
gewinnen sagen uns experten vor der
landtagswahl beobachten wir den
wahlkampf
in der kleinstadt querfurt macht der afg
ortsverband mobil hans-thomas
tillschneider ist der vize chef im
landesverband
er sorgt für die auto- beflaggung
tillschneider gehört auch zum rechten
flügel der partei gegen eine beobachtung
durch den verfassungsschutz wehrt sich
sein landesverband vor gericht
die einzige partei die die krone ein dem
muss macht haben ablehnt alle anderen
alle anderen sind wieder mal
gleichgeschalteten verlassen einer
anderen politischen fragen
gleichgeschaltet vertreten eine selbe
meinung und die fts die einzige echte
opposition die afg nimmt kein blatt vor
den mund stellt die systemfrage
der kurs von parteichef morton ist der
hfg hier vor ort nicht radikal genug
[Applaus]
wenige wochen später wolmirstedt nicht
weit von magdeburg entfernt
11.000 einwohner die arbeitslosigkeit
hoch die wirtschaftsleistung rückläufig
es gibt viele probleme in sachsen anhalt
es ist kalt an diesem tag die
wahlkämpfer der afg sind früh auf den
beinen
sie haben sich viel vorgenommen erneut
treffen wir hans-thomas tillschneider
den fdp vize chef in sachsen anhalt
seine botschaft die afg wieder einmal
gegen den rest der politischen welt die
keine fdp keine grünen keine linken wir
haben einen großen einheitsblock gegen
deutschland und wir haben die
alternative für deutschland was viele in
der afg über andere parteien denken
lesen wir in den geschlossenen chat
gruppen hier diskutieren auch
fdp-landtagsabgeordnete
vorstandsmitglieder und kandidaten für
öffentliche ämter
eine besondere hassfigur in den afd
foren ist die kanzlerin
manche wünschen ihr sogar den tod merkel
braucht ein fluchtfahrzeug
es geht ihr an die wäsche die zeitnahe
ich werde einen antrag stellen für die
todesstrafe
sie ist ein teufel heißt es ein anderer
chatpartner beschreibt sie als satanist
in und fluch für die indigenen völker
europas das deutsche volk ist so dumm
dass lacht noch wenn es zur schlachtbank
geführt wird
[Musik]
die cdu wird zu merkels volksverräter
parteien der kampf gilt den altparteien
und der regierungs diktatur gechattet
wird in den afd foren in teilen mit
pseudonymen verfasser namentlich zu
stellen ist dann nicht möglich und es
sind viele einträge die offene system
feindschaft dokumentieren
seit jahrzehnten gehört ursula münch zu
den führenden politologin in deutschland
sie ist direktorin der akademie für
politische bildung in tutzing und kennt
die diskussionskultur in den
rechtsextremen chat gruppen und ihre
wirkung
da findet also eine ständige
radikalisierung stadt das niveau des
erregungs niveau des rassistischen
niveau des frauenfeindlichen die wo das
demokratiefeindliche niveau
das wird ständig nach oben gepusht das
ist dramatisch
das macht ihm sorgen und gleichzeitig
weiß man nicht was man im grunde dagegen
wie man dagegen angehen
es soll also politische bildung nützt da
leider herzlich wenig seit sechs jahren
ist jörg meyer fdp bundesvorsitzender
sein weg führte über die kritik an der
finanzpolitik der eu in die rechte
partei erzählt zum national
konservativen lager für ihn steht außer
frage dass die rechtsextremisten in
seiner partei noch lange keine mehrheit
hätten
die wehr sogar sicher dass wir eine
mehrheit haben die mehrheit ist nicht
unbedingt der lautere teil der partei
und das wird dann dieses etwas schräge
bild auf die partei so als sei das eine
partei von von von krakeelen und und
system umstürzen
dem ist nicht so aber ich kann verstehen
dass menschen das draußen wahrnehmen
weil das natürlich medial viel stärker
kolportiert wird als die ganz normale
afd
die in vergleichsweise langweiligen
fachausschüssen arbeiten die sache
anträge einbringen in parlamenten und
sowas darüber wird nicht groß berichtet
nein ich glaube man kann nicht so sein
ist marginal ihren landesverband von dem
für merkel geführt wird dann ist das was
glaube ich auch öffentliche
aufmerksamkeit verdient ja es gibt da
unterschiedliche mentalitäten glaube ich
bis zum heutigen tage zwischen west und
ost also weil nur als gedankenexperiment
lassen sind wir allemal in nordrhein
westfalen antreten als als als
landeschef dann glaube ich hätte dir
schon überhaupt nicht die spur einer
chance sich als landeschef zu etablieren
ein fdp-politiker wie heute habe im
westen weit weniger chancen
davon sind auch experten überzeugt auf
der anderen seite haben die
landtagswahlen im westen parteichef
wollten unter druck gesetzt die afg
verliert dort ein drittel der wähler
viele in der afg machen dafür den neuen
kurs der west verbände verantwortlich
ich habe da eine völlig klare position
ich stehe zu unseren politischen system
der parlamentarischen demokratie ich
will kein anderes wäre ein anderes will
sollte sich eine andere partei suchen
das ist nicht die afd parteichef leuten
versucht nun die rechtsextremen aus der
partei zu drängen die er jahrelang
toleriert hat wegen seiner vergangenheit
in einer neonazi-gruppe wird
beispielsweise andreas kalbitz aus der
partei geworfen
pötke verliert damit seinen wichtigsten
strategen versuche björn röcke selbst
rauszuwerfen sind bislang gescheitert
der konfrontationskurs birgt auch für
morton risiken die lesart der af
dresdner anderer die leser ist dass der
erfolg der vergangenen sieben jahre
darin besteht dass es gelungen ist die
gemäßigten und die radikalen kräfte in
einen kontext zu binden unter einem dach
zu versammeln
und wenn ein teil wegfällt wird die
kraft die explosion die dynamik dieser
partei nicht mehr die sein wie sie
vorher gewesen ist insofern ist das
plädoyer von herrn oyten für eine
gemäßigtere gangart natürlich eine
dimension der abwendung vom bisherigen
erfolgsweg
brüssel ende april seit 2000 17 sitzt
afg chef leuten als abgeordneter im eu
parlament treffen in seinem büro wir
zeigen ihm auszüge aus chat gruppen an
denen sich auch fdp funktionäre
beteiligt haben lange momente des prüfen
deutschland wird bereits seit
jahrzehnten mit kultur fremden
völkerschaften überflutet ich könnte
kotzen wenn ich muslime höhere die
fortpflanzungs mutigen aus dem
morgenland
wenn ich bin wenn ich das jetzt schauen
wir da das ist dann schon schon arg
schräge dinge dabei ich bin ich bin
eigentlich darüber gestoppt das diesen
diesen menschen
wenn ich das hier lese nicht klar ist
wie stark sie das ansehen von tausenden
von parteimitgliedern schädigen den das
so fern ist wie mir das auch ist ja also
das sind zum teil eben hier vereinzelt
regelrecht menschenverachtende
positionen leuten weiß das sind
positionen die dem image das er seiner
partei geben möchte schaden holen wir
uns unser land zurück deutschland den
deutschen 100 jahre bis es keine weißen
mehr gibt für parteichef leuten sei das
aber nur eine minderheit
wir haben im moment um die 31.000
mitglieder dafür sind die 500 schlimm
diese dieser solchen dingen raushauen da
sind noch ein paar in dem in dem
weiteren dunst hält die würden so was
nicht raushalten aber die teilen ist
vielleicht implizit aber wir haben eine
ähnlich große gruppe an leuten die
wirklich die sorge um unser land in die
in die afg hinein getrieben hat wie mich
auch und denen denen solche menschen
letztlich menschenfeindlichen positionen
völlig völlig fernsehen und trotzdem
rechtsextreme libyen höcke besetzen in
der afg seit jahren spitzenämter sind in
ihren landesverbänden nahezu
unumstritten da zu beziffern experten
die zahl der rechtsextremisten weit
höher als der parteivorsitzende
es wird immer davon gesprochen dass der
extreme rechtsextreme teil der afd
etwa 30 prozent der mitglieder und
funktionäre ausmacht und der andere teil
entsprechend größer ist aber die
artikulation nach außen wird sehr stark
durch die radikalen zornigen und
extremen kräfte bestimmt jahre lang geht
es für die afg nur nach vorn 2013
gegründet schafft sie in kürzester zeit
den sprung in alle landesparlamente und
in den bundestag
[Applaus]
durch die flüchtlingskrise bekommt die
partei großen zulauf über eine million
menschen kommen allein 2015 über die
deutsche grenze geschickt nutzt die afg
ängste ködert mit rechter propaganda
wählerstimmen
man muss berücksichtigen dass wir über
die empirische sozialforschung wissen
dass es in der deutschen bevölkerung
rechtsextremistische einstellungs
potenziale gibt die um die zehn bis 20
prozent liegen
die lange zeit von keiner partei
erfolgreich mobilisiert werden konnten
rechtsextremes gedankengut hat in der
afg im flügel schon vor jahren eine
heimat gefunden
das wird bei den jährlichen kyffhäuser
treffen deutlich lange zeit sieht es
nach einem zweckbündnis der beiden afd
lager aus heute spricht für die
rechtsextremisten heute lautet die frage
scharf oder wolf und ich nein wir
entscheiden uns in dieser lage wolf zu
sein möglichst positionen waren lange
für parteichef wollten kein problem
gast besucher und lobende worte nun
spreche ich bereits zum dritten mal in
folge auf dem großen jahrestreffen des
flügels 2009 10 kommt es dann zum bruch
2020 lösen leuten und der bundesvorstand
die strukturen des flügels um jörn
böcker auf ich glaub da steckt viel
hybris und viel anmaßungen drin wenn er
meint er müsse die geschicke der partei
bestimmt dann soll er kandidieren für
den bundesvorsitz und soll versuchen
nach selber 200 wird man sehen ob ihm
das gelingt oder nicht sollte es ihm
gelingen wird diese partei eine andere
sein
wichtige fragen im raum steht deren
wollten tut doch jetzt müsse was gegen
den wirkstoff selbst auch beim
stand in einer reihe wie bewerten sie
den besuch dieses treffens heute ja das
ist das ist genau der punkt ich habe es
ja gerade gesagt es war der versuch die
zu integrieren
und der war ein irrtum
das ging nicht und das habe ich gemerkt
das ist das ist eine geschichte dreimal
auf diesen treffen 2016 17 18 und 18 ist
mir ultimativ klar geworden hier bin ich
falsch das hat keinen sinn
das geht in eine richtung die gehe ich
keinesfalls mit es geht um die zukunft
der partei
und meistens eigene perspektive denn
auch im westen hat der rechte
parteiflügel anhänger es ist anfang märz
die offenbacher afg hat björn rücker
eingeladen organisatorin christine sie
sollte bereits wegen rassistischen
witzen und hitler bildern in internen
jets aus der partei geworfen werden wie
immer bei höcker auftritten liegt
spannung in der luft
ordner gehen in stellung die meisten von
ihnen haben einen migrationshintergrund
ausgerechnet sie sollen den
nationalisten höcke vor gegen
demonstranten schützen
rund 50 afd anhänger sind darum härte
zuzujubeln
auf der anderen seite rund 1000
gegendemonstranten lautstarker protest
rangelei werkes einzug
er heizt die stimmung an liefert
verschwörungstheorie kroner sei
angeblich eine waffe gegen die ah fdp
hessen liebe landsleute liebe patrioten
wer waren die nutznießer von cola vor
allen dingen die verbrauchten partei die
um ihren einfluss bangen die wirkliche
opposition in deutschland die afd soll
vom kontakt mit dem bürger abgeschnitten
werden auch wir wollten mit björn höckel
reden doch eine interviewanfrage lehnt
er ab gegendemonstranten wollen die
veranstaltung stürmen
die lage droht zu eskalieren und die afg
provoziert
hier drücken so schön schreiben
ich hoffe dass sie alle geimpft sind
oder sie schnellstens impfen lassen
vielleicht werden sie lösen sich dann
ganz schnell los
nach zwei stunden geht die veranstaltung
zu ändern
anfang mai wir treffen christine töne in
offenbach wieder
wir wollen wissen wie der rechte
parteiflügel im westen denkt wie
positioniert man sich hier zum
richtungsstreit in offenbach leben
menschen aus 160 nationen knapp 63
prozent der einwohner haben einen
migrationshintergrund
das berge konflikte sagt thüne und gibt
sich als hüterin der heimat geht einfach
darum dieses land muss wieder gesund
werden auch mit den ausländer gar kein
thema aber es nur soweit gesund werden
dass wir nicht die eigene bevölkerung
vernachlässigen da gibt es nämlich auch
viele denen ich nicht gut geld die sich
dann im stich gelassen fühlt
da heißt es dann ja oft gehen gibt ja
alles und es gibt ja nichts ist das so
in der realität ist es nicht so ganz
ehrlich jeder ist seines glückes schmied
s gibt ausländers geht arme deutsche
jeder kann sich bewähren kann etwas
draus machen es wird hier keiner in
diesem staat fallengelassen das ist
nicht so aber der eindruck entsteht
und oft sind es genau diese eindrücke
mit denen die afd wahlkampf macht
vorurteile die auch schönes vorbild von
höcker geschickt verbreitet auch wenn
christine töne höckers afd kurs im
westen umsetzen möchte versteht sie
nicht warum der streit zwischen den
beiden strömungen der partei öffentlich
ausgetragen wird
ich betrachte und bei als familie
wir sollten uns intern die köpfe main
wegen einschlagen wir sollten einen raum
rein gehen main wegen einen boxclub und
kloppen ganz egal aber geben wenn man
das nach außen trägt und nach außen
signalisiert die person will ich nicht
von der distanzieren wir uns das würde
keine familie mit ihrem kind machen
bochum hier lebt der afg stratege markus
scheer
er sieht das ganz anders erzählt zum
lager der wollten befürwortern in meinem
kreisverband haben wir polnischer
herkunft iranischer herkunft
griechischer herkunft wir haben ein
buntes potpourri an menschen und gerade
hier im ruhrgebiet sind wir doch immer
mit diesen leuten gemeinsam aufgewachsen
wir sind höckers völkische positionen
ein dorn im auge sein ziel ist eine
bündelung der gemäßigten kräfte um den
vormarsch des flügels zu stoppen sind
keine rechtsradikale oder also partei
wir uns immer gerne unterstellt wird und
deswegen ist eine bahn bau nach ganz
außen rechts wichtig weil es in der tat
viel fläche rechts gibt für die wir
nicht stehen und für die wir auch nicht
sagen ich mein herz genommen werden
wolle und doch gibt es einen
richtungskampf mit auswirkungen auf
künftige wahlen
eine gemäßigtere afd wurde tatsächlich
im westen zu größeren wahlerfolgen
führen würde eine stärkere konkurrenz
gegenüber den etablierten parteien
bedeuten
das ist aber ein programm was
offenkundig in den ostdeutschen ländern
weniger ankommt dort ist man stärker
gewählt klare system feindliche
positionen zu formulieren und hat damit
ja auch erkennbaren erfolg parteichef
leuten in seinem arbeitszimmer videochat
mit afg funktionären aus baden
württemberg es ist eine
standortbestimmung nach den verlorenen
landtagswahlen im westen
es ist ein streiter vielen ebenen auch
leuten selbst wird zur zielscheibe
der hammer ist dass diese leute sich da
so als die aufrechten patrioten und die
wahren demokraten bezeichnet was nicht
alles ja aber da im grunde genommen ja
mehr oder minder und gewaltfantasien
ausleben ich hatte letzte woche auch
wieder sondern chat gehört da hat jemand
gesagt also wann müsste mich zur strecke
bringen und bomben sollten in meinem
leben bunker die turniere lotter so
verquast zeigt wo ich denke welche marke
kann man eigentlich haben auch in den
internen jets zu denen wir einen zugang
bekamen ist die wachsende distanzen zu
morden spürbaren wie kriegen wir den
leuten los
freiwillig wird er die fleischtöpfe
nicht räumen wollen
makabre videos machen die runde
tanzende sargträger feiern wollten der
graben ist so tief die positionen sind
so unterschiedlich wenn man sie zu ende
denkt dass eine vermittlung nicht
möglich ist deshalb sprechen wir ja auch
davon dass es sich hier um zwei parteien
in einer partei handelt und gleichzeitig
ist es aber richtig dass eben diese
erfolgsformel von gemäßigt und radikal
in der vergangenheit durch die wähler
honoriert wurde
der richtungsstreit geht auf einer neuen
ebene weiter
bei der wahl der afg spitzenkandidaten
für die bundestagswahl angetreten sind
zwei kandidaten per aus dem neuen lager
joanna krupa und ihr duo partner joachim
wundrak früher general leutnant der
luftwaffe als kandidatin des rechten
flügels gelten fraktionschefin alice
weidl und co parteichef timoschtschuk
ende mai setzt sich das duo weidl und
szukala deutlich durch es ist eine
richtungsentscheidung wieder einmal auch
wenn seine kandidaten weit unbekannter
sind ist es für jörg leuten eine
[ __ ] die partei steht diesmal
offensichtlich nicht hinter ihm
die rechtsextremen in der partei haben
immer weniger scheu ihre überzeugungen
zu äußern
das offenbaren die chat verläufe der
internen diskussionsgruppen
es gehe um die vernichtung der
souveränen völker des sein zitat die
dämonischen globalisten amberg linkes
internationalistische und
selbstgefälliges packen
klose rothschild banker würden dem land
zu setzen
es gehe um die neue weltordnung und die
entmachtung der souveränen völkern
sollten sich die rechtsextremen jetzt in
der afg endgültig durchsetzen würde
parteichef wollten für sich daraus
konsequenzen ziehen wenn wir anfangen
hier in einem ultra nationalismus
abzurutschen
in rassistische positionen das geht mit
mir nicht dafür stehe ich nicht zur
verfügung also ich bin ich das
bürgerliche feigenblatt für positionen
tiefst ablehnung eine aussage an der
sich parteichef wollten künftig messen
lassen muss
die partei muss sich für eine der beiden
richtungen entscheiden entweder eine
formale mäßigung mit der option
irgendwann mal koalitionspartner zu sein
dann würde man aber die ostdeutschen
landesverbände verlieren oder sie muss
sich auf eine fundamental oppositionelle
orientierung einstellen mit einer klaren
system ablehnung in einem sehr offenen
sinne wie das gegenwärtig schon in den
ostdeutschen landesverbänden praxis ist
in der ard wird seit ihrer gründung
gekämpft heraus bugsiert kompromisse
geschlossen wieder ausgeschlossen wieder
integriert wenn man so will kann man
sagen ist die afg eine permanente
kampfzone aber bis zur bundestagswahl
wird so etwas wie ein moratorium geben
und danach werden die messer heraus
geholt
die afg am scheideweg obsiegen die
extremisten um björn röcke oder das
lager um jörg neuten für eine der
gruppen dürfte es bald keinen platz mehr
geben in der partei solange dieser
richtungsstreit aber nicht entschieden
ist ist die afg eine partei mit zwei
gesichtern